hi everyone
thanks for joining us today for a
session we're going to be talking about
what's new
as gk turns five i'm true brad stock
product leader for gke and joining me
today is alex zakanov
engineering director for gke now it's
pretty amazing to think
that we're celebrating gk's fifth
birthday today
now i know we may have promised cake but
unfortunately that cake is a lie
and what you're gonna have to put up
with is just this virtual version
alex and i had talked about whether it
was a good idea to sing happy birthday
to gka
in this session but thankfully due to
the fact we're both awful singers we
declined
so with that i'd like to turn over to
alex
welcome today is an amazing day for us
and we celebrate that together with all
our customers
customers who use gte to scale their
applications to meet
huge demands of black friday february
customers who use gte to run their
banking and financial applications
customers who use gte to do medical
research
or learn how to optimize self-driving
cars
that's an amazing day for us the journey
towards that day started way in the past
it goes
back to 2006 when google
open sourced the modern concept of linux
containers
that's where we started in 2012
google was ready to take the next step
and to start the work
on bringing container management at
scale
and all experience that google
internally had with the technology
to the outside world and in 2014
kubernetes was unveiled
setting the new standard on what it
means
to run cloud native infrastructure and
cloud native applications
a year later in august 2015
gt was born making it simple
and available for customers to run
kubernetes clusters customers
loved the experience with gke
and kubernetes but they told us that
it's not enough
they told that they got from a legacy on
premium applications
to cloud native applications running in
a modern cloud
is too big that they need help
on that journey and we listen to them
and in 2018 we announced
gtk and prem bringing the power
of gte to customer data centers
and allowing them to modernize in place
customers told us repeatedly that gte is
a gold standard
and they need to make sure that they can
leverage the gold standard
no matter where they're running and this
year
we announced gt on iws
bringing gt power to multi-cloud
customers
who want to have consistent high quality
operators experience
across on-prem and multi-cloud
with that we have amazing platform
but it's only start of the journey there
is
way more to do and if we're looking on
the next five years
we see a world where every workflow
will run on top of containers and on top
of kubernetes
no matter if it's butcher clothes or
real time no matter if it's a legacy
workflow
or modern cloud native application
and that's a high demand that we need to
meet
making sure that we have
reliable secure scalable platform
to run any type of workload
so how are we going to meet the demand
first google continues heavily invest
in open source kubernetes
helping with scale security and
reliability
of kubernetes google
is a number one contributor of investing
all other major cloud providers
as well as other companies that support
kubernetes distributions
google funds the infrastructure for
kubernetes development
kubernetes is built and distributed on
gt itself
and all kubernetes testing is run on gt
with all that kubernetes is still hot
kubernetes is extremely powerful
platform
that power comes with responsibility
and no offense to kelsey
but kubernetes shouldn't have to be
the hard way and huge thank you to
kelsey
and our devrel team for bringing all the
feedback
on what we need to simplify the
environment
and gt is our answer
to simplifying kubernetes with
g key we take complexity of kubernetes
and we're shifting it from a car being
customer responsibility
to be google responsibility with gt
google sre team is responsible for
operating gt clusters
in highly reliable and scalable way
google security team
is responsible for analyzing and
addressing
all security threats across a full step
starting from gt kubernetes itself going
to linux
and going even to your language itself
which is go
vs and google development team
is responsible for taking all the
knowledge
that we get from iranian meanings of
workloads
on top of containers and converting it
in a set of new functionality and
innovation
for our customers one concrete example
of that innovation
is what we're doing with auto scaling
functionality
google constantly watches internal and
external workloads running on top of
containers
and builds
machine learning predictable models on
how to scale workloads in the most
efficient way and
we bring that knowledge that
intelligence to our customers
gt allows you automatically skill
infrastructure
supporting horizontal or no dog scaling
as well as dynamically scale your
workloads
supporting both horizontal polarity
healing
as well as vertical or darker scaling
making sure
that your workloads run efficiently and
can
meet high skill demands
a concrete example of that is our
partnership is wikipedia
a major in the indonesian retailer
that needs to meet high school
requirements
of their peak retail system wikipedia
partnered with google
to optimize their environment to make
sure that
on one side they can run in a cost
effective way
but on other side when their customer
traffic increases
they can dynamically meet those demands
another major dimension is scale
as new major workloads
move to containers and kubernetes the
demand for scale
increases this year gt
announced 15 000 node support for
kubernetes clusters running on top of
gte
and that was done in a partnership with
out of customers
such as buyers crop signs
that uses gte to
run genotype analysis analyzing 15
billion genotypes per as well as twitter
who's using gke to power real-time
communication platform
across the world please attend twitter
session
to learn more about how gta is using how
twitter is using gta
to move their mates and aurora workloads
and mega clusters to kubernetes and gt
clusters
[Music]
another interesting use case is
gaming
where gt is partnered with the phonic
phonics labs this gaming applications
whenever you
launch a new title it's extremely hard
almost impossible to predict exact scale
that you will need
as a result in many cases you need to
design
almost for ultimate scalability
phony clubs partnered with google
and gk team around launch of their new
title
we designed the infrastructure
to make sure that it will meet the
skinning needs
as well as partner partnered with them
on reviewing best practices for their
application layer
as a result of that whenever
the new title was large and on the first
week
number of gamers crossed 4 million
gamers we are able to meet those demands
without reach next
we are taking all that co innovation
with our customers
and bringing it to the next wave of our
customers and you will talk more about
that
thanks alex it's great to see that level
of partnership with our customers
because that has been the heart of gke
if we go way back to the very beginning
the first phase of gk and kubernetes is
really around the builders
these are companies put a heavy engine
investment and their own time
into building new core functionality
into kubernetes
and we're able to leverage that through
gk from there
we move to the next phase which is the
cloud scalers that's where great firms
such as shopify
and spotify work with google and use g
key to be able to
obtain that huge massive global scale
they need
to grow their businesses to where they
are in 2020.
from there we've entered a very
different phase of kubernetes
this is where the previous companies
were very cloud native
starting the cloud and grew in the cloud
instead we're working with a far
larger number of customers we're
actually moving from on-prem
or moving from vmware into containers
and the needs of these customers
what many of you need is very different
from the customers at the beginning
instead they're looking for a lot more
simplicity
rather than having 50 different options
to do something in full choice
they want to have it a lot more
automated they want it more opinionated
and they want more help from google
so they're not having to build it
themselves and this is where we get to
the next phase of kubernetes adoption
and where we're really taking gke this
is the wide-scale adoption of kubernetes
across enterprises just like alex
mentioned and what they're really
looking for
is to be able to take all the learnings
google has across
its massive fleet of both internal
systems
as well as gk as a whole globally and
use that to be able to automate much of
what
they do to run the system so they don't
have to worry about it
now a great example of this change is
actually what we've seen with the
support of windows
previously and for a long time gk was
just linux
and this is great a lot of great scale
but the challenge was
much of a businesses workloads
especially those that didn't start in
the cloud
were trapped on windows servers and
vmware which made that modernization
journey a lot easier
by supporting windows as a first-class
citizen and having it fully j and gke
it's really opened up a lot of the
migration of the cloud of these works
and also consolidation onto kubernetes
clusters
hand-in-hand with that though it's not
just kubernetes support
it's helped able to migrate those
vm-based apps
into containers which can be quite a
struggle this is where migrate for
anthos
which also works great for migrate with
gke such
you don't need anfields to help you in
an automated fashion
move your applications from vm
containers be it in the cloud
or on-prem into gka
this takes a lot of the risk a lot of
the time a lot of the difficulty and
instead
the tooling does it for you which can
greatly ramp up
your journey into gke
now from there we need to make the
entire thing simple
one of the things i get often from
customers is hey we're on kubernetes
and it's almost an implied question mark
so what do you go from there
because that first step of creating a
cluster can be quite difficult
and that's been a huge amount of our
investment over the past year and a half
is to simplify that experience take
creating the cluster for the first time
in auto way automate away much of what
you'd normally be doing
so rather than having to take 20 minutes
and many many steps
instead you can be live in your first
kubernetes cluster in only minutes
and this really shifts kubernetes from
the hard way
and i personally learned from kelseat
high tires great book
and went through that lab experience so
thank you kelsey but the
honestly i don't want many large
enterprises want to have to do that
they instead want to be able to do this
smoothly so they can go from their first
dev cluster
to their first production cluster to
their second production cluster to their
third and so on
very smoothly without all this
additional effort for each one
and that's where gk really stands out
and you'll continue to see
more and more simplification and gk
doing more and more of kubernetes
so you have to do less now just like
your initial experience shouldn't be
hard
day two operations shouldn't be scary
but unfortunately they are for
any people this means how do you keep up
with patching
how do you handle upgrades be it for
stateless or stateful workloads
how do you handle security or issues
that pop up the last minute
this can often be a very time-consuming
initiative
that can slow down those full production
rollouts that's why specifically we've
made a
very strong investment on this and
leveraging what we've done with our sre
teams and ngprod
to look across the entire fleet to
simplify things for you
great example of this is release
channels what this allows you to do
is pick a ga version of kubernetes so
rapid regular and stable or all ga
and decide based on your risk profile or
your particular workload risk profile
what version do you want now what i mean
by this
is not everyone wants to be bleeding
edge and not everyone wants me back a
couple releases
so if you've got a workload that can
never afford to be going down you'd like
a much longer soak time of this version
of kubernetes
out in the wild for a long period stable
is the best bet for you
but if you want something a little more
current you can use regular
and if you want the latest and greatest
of kubernetes and we certify
the newest version out in oss very
quickly you can choose rapid
now the cool thing about this is as gk
certifies the next version of rapid
regular stable
we move it up for you and automatically
do the upgrades
and this is huge because it takes that
risk takes all the security patching
takes all the testing out of your hands
and allows us to do it
and also look across the entire fleet so
you benefit from that as well
and that makes day two a lot simpler and
a lot more stable no matter who you are
really good example this is actually the
work that face it did with us
and face it runs a massive platform for
online multiplayer games
and before they took advantage of surge
upgrades they're spending about two
weeks
upgrading their environments for any of
you who lived through this you know how
scary upgrades can be
via databases or via kubernetes and be
able to reduce the risk
and leverage automated and tested tools
allowed facing to go from that two weeks
to less than a day the important thing
for this
is less risk and also it freed up their
team to work on other tasks
rather than focusing on upgrades and
building all their own scripts
which over time can be brittle and
that's not where you want your best
engineers and your platform team to
focus on
now if you look at where we're going
we're really just getting started
as we've spoken about a heavy focus for
gke
has been taking the complexity of
kubernetes and greatly simplifying it
but that's not the only thing we're
doing if you look at scaling
traditionally people talk about how far
they can go
and what's been key for that as alex
spoke about
is actually the fact that it was done in
partnership with customers like bear
and twitter so we're running real
workloads and seeing what was happening
with them
and testing all parts of gke such we can
scale at small workloads
large workloads or any combination of
what you can throw at us
now the other side of this coin is how
do we actually optimize
costs it's great if you can scale up and
handle that maximum capacity at any time
but truly you want to be able to scale
down to meet the needs of your business
as well
to free up compute and network costs to
be able to really save you money
and this is where the team that's doing
this has focus on that scale down
in optimizing for costs this can be with
efficient vms a new offering for gcp
that brings down your overall compute
cost
where gk can do that certification and
testing ahead
so that you don't have to or working in
partnership with us
to take a workload that completely
changes globally depending on time of
day
which we actually do with openx and just
like the session with twitter
there's a really great one with openx on
what they did to handle a global
advertising
application and control costs at the
same time
now along with that there continues to
be a lot of investment security
this is key this is something you want
some of the global fleet to be taken
responsibility for
in constantly looking at harding your
application for you
rather than worrying about it so i think
as you look at kubernetes
really our innovation is just getting
started and i'd love to turn it over to
alex zakimoff now
thank you drew innovation at the core of
google dna
dna and we had amazing five years of
innovation
and we are looking for the next five
years
of bringing more innovation to you the
customer
please stay tuned for additional
announcements from us in the q4
this year and next year letting you
simplify your operation to scale
your workloads to run efficiently
as well as making sure that all your
enterprise security needs and compliance
is met thank you
you